Výraz kvantová teleportace může znít jako věc ze sci-fi, ale jak si povíme v dnešní epizodě
Qiskit in the Classroom, jde o velmi reálnou a velmi užitečnou techniku pro kvantovou komunikaci a
sítě. Vítej v Qiskit in the Classroom. V této sérii použijeme Qiskit k prozkoumání základních
konceptů běžně probíraných v kurzech zaměřených na kvantové výpočty. Každé video je doprovázeno interaktivním modulem
odkazovaným v popisu níže, takže se na něj určitě podívej. Teleportace je v tuto chvíli tak trochu sci-fi a fantasy
klišé. Osoba nebo předmět zmizí z jednoho místa a okamžitě se objeví někde jinde.
Jakkoli by to bylo skvělé, bohužel tento druh teleportace je přinejmenším nemožný. Porušovalo by to kosmický
rychlostní limit – nic nemůže cestovat rychleji než světlo. Ale kvantová teleportace je
možná. Při kvantové teleportaci lze informace – ne hmotu – přenášet mezi dvěma
vzdálenými místy. Vše, co potřebuješ, je pár provázaných částic, jedna na každém místě, a způsob, jak komunikovat klasické
informace mezi těmito dvěma místy. Tento protokol byl vyvinut v roce 1993 týmem
kvantových vědců, včetně Charlese Bennetta z IBM. Nazvali ho kvantovou teleportací, protože podobně jako ve
sci-fi verzi, kvantová informace zmizela z jednoho místa a objevila se na jiném vzdáleném
místě, aniž by kdy procestovala mezilehlý prostor. Může to znít jako magie, ale jak uvidíme, není na tom nic
tajemného ani magického. Je to umožněno fenoménem kvantového provázání spolu s klasickou
komunikací. Dnes si projdeme protokol kvantové teleportace a to, jak funguje. Pak ho uvedeme do
praxe na skutečném kvantovém počítači a teleportujeme stav qubit z jedné strany IBM kvantového procesoru na
druhou. Takhle kvantová teleportace funguje. Předpokládejme, že máme dvě osoby – Alice a Boba – oddělené
velkou vzdáleností. Řekněme, že Alice má qubit. Nazveme ho qubit Q jen pro pohodlí. A je v nějakém
neznámém kvantovém stavu sq, kde alpha 0 a alpha 1 jsou komplexní
čísla. Alice chce svůj stav poslat Bobovi, ale nemá způsob, jak mu skutečně poslat qubit samotný. Může to být proto, že
je příliš daleko, nebo možná ani přesně neví, kde Bob je, takže neví, kam ho poslat. Naštěstí
tito přátelé sdílejí pár provázaných qubitů A a B, kde Alice má qubit A a Bob má qubit B. A
tyto qubity jsou provázané. Provázáním myslím to, že ačkoli jsou oba qubity odděleny velkou
vzdáleností, jejich stavy jsou korelovány způsobem, který klasická fyzika neumí vysvětlit. Tento provázaný pár se
nazývá Ebit, který lze použít jako zdroj v kvantových výpočtech a komunikaci.
V tomto případě může Alice použít Ebit jako zdroj k přenosu svých kvantových informací Bobovi. Abychom viděli jak,
začněme zápisem sdíleného stavu všech tří těchto qubitů, kde jsem seřadil qubity poněkud libovolně
v tuto chvíli, ale toto pořadí bude praktické, až spustíme náš experiment na Qiskit. V Qiskit je standardní způsob
řazení qubitů zprava doleva. Takže stav qubit nula se objeví vpravo.
Rozviňme stav trochu a přepišme ho takto. Prvním krokem v našem teleportačním protokolu je
to, aby Alice provázala svůj datový qubit s její polovinou Ebit qubit pomocí C knot gate. C knot neboli řízený NOT
gate změní stav jednoho qubit – cílového qubit – v závislosti na stavu jiného qubit – řídicího qubit.
Pokud je řídicí qubit ve stavu nula, nic se s cílovým nestane. A pokud je řídicí qubit ve
stavu jedna, cílový qubit se překlopí. V tomto případě tedy bude Alicin datový qubit Q řídicím qubit a
její Ebit qubit A bude cílovým qubit. Takže první dva členy se C knotem vůbec nezměnily, ale
poslední dva ano, protože řídicí qubit Q byl ve stavu jedna. Pak Alice
aplikuje Hadamard gate na svůj datový qubit Q, který převede stav 0 na stav 1/odmocnina(2) krát (0 + 1) a stav 1 na
1/odmocnina(2) krát (0 - 1). Přeskočím zde jednoduchou algebru, kterou si můžeš zkusit doplnit sám, pokud chceš.
Ale po přeuspořádání některých členů dostaneš stav, který vypadá takto. Takže teď vypadá tříqubitový
provázaný stav Alice a Boba jako naprostý chaos. Ale podívej se, co se stane, když Alice změří oba své qubity. Tříqubitový
stav se částečně zhroutí do jednoho z těchto čtyř
členů. A v každém případě Bobovi zbude superpozice se amplitudami, které jsou příbuzné Alicinu
počátečnímu neznámému stavu. Pamatuj, že amplitudy jsou alpha 0 a alpha 1. Takže
například pokud Alice změří oba qubity jako nula, Bobův stav se zhroutí do tohoto členu – původního
neznámého stavu, který Alice chtěla teleportovat. Ale pokud Alice změří nula na qubit A a jedna na qubit Q, Bobův
stav bude tento. Tento stav lze transformovat do původního stavu qubit Q, pokud Bob
aplikuje Z gate, který překlopí toto znaménko zde. Ale Bob nebude vědět, že to má udělat,
dokud se nedozví, co Alice naměřila. Takže dalším krokem v protokolu je, aby Alice zavolala Bobovi a řekla mu,
co naměřila. Poté, co to bude vědět, bude vědět, jaké operace má provést na svém qubit, aby odpovídal
Alicinu původnímu stavu. Zde je tabulka čtyř možných měření a čtyř možných operací, které Bob
bude muset provést na svém qubit na základě těchto měření. Bob možná bude muset aplikovat Z gate, X gate nebo obojí, aby
transformoval svůj qubit tak, aby odpovídal Alicinu původnímu qubit. Tento poslední krok, kdy Alice volá Bobovi, je mimochodem důvodem,
proč kvantová teleportace neporušuje kauzalitu. I když se Bobův stav okamžitě zhroutil, když Alice změřila
své qubity, Bob nemohl z tohoto stavu získat žádné informace, dokud mu Alice neřekla, co naměřila. A
ten hovor byl omezen rychlostí světla. Prošli jsme spoustou detailní matematiky, takže neuvěřitelný fakt,
že jsme právě teleportovali kvantové informace, se mohl ztratit. Ale je to skutečně úžasné. Použitím
provázání jako zdroje mohla Alice provést měření, které zničí kvantové informace uložené u ní, a nechat je
objevit na jiném vzdáleném místě u Boba. Tato vzdálenost může být stovky, ba tisíce kilometrů. Ještě
úžasnější je, že tento protokol ani nevyžaduje, aby Alice přesně věděla, kde Bob je. Pokud sdílejí Ebit
a mohou spolu klasicky komunikovat, kvantová teleportace bude fungovat. Teď se podívejme, jak to funguje
WEBVTT
s Qiskit a skutečně teleportuj kvantový stav na kvantovém počítači.
Začneme se třemi qubity – jedním pro datový qubit Q a qubity A a B, které tvoří Ebit. Začínáme
vytvořením Ebitu. Aplikujeme Hadamard na qubit A, za nímž následuje C knot
mezi A a B, čímž vytvoříme provázaný stav, o který nám jde.
Pak připravíme Alicin qubit Q v náhodném kvantovém stavu aplikováním náhodné unitární operace znázorněné tímto rámečkem označeným
U. Pak přichází teleportace. Nejprve C knot mezi qubity Q a A. Pak Hadamard na
qubit Q. Pak měření částečně zhroutí stav tak, aby byl pouze Bobův qubit B v superpozici.
V tomto bodě by Alice zavolala Bobovi a řekla mu, co naměřila. Pak by Bob aplikoval
gate v závislosti na těchto měřeních. Tyto červeně orámované rámečky označují podmíněné gate. První znamená,
že Bob aplikuje X gate na svůj qubit, pokud qubit A je změřen jako jedna. A
druhý znamená, že aplikuje Z gate, také pokud qubit Q je změřen jako jedna.
Takže teď by Bob měl mít qubit ve stejném stavu, v jakém byl Alicin qubit v tomto bodě – po aplikaci unitárního gate.
Pokud vše proběhlo podle plánu, teleportovali jsme kvantový stav. Ale jak to ověříme? Můžeme spustit
stejný circuit, ale s jednou malou změnou.
Přidali jsme sem další unitární operaci úplně na konci circuit aplikovanou na Bobův qubit. Tato unitární operace je inverzí
té, kterou jsme aplikovali na začátku na Alicin qubit. Myšlenka je taková, že pokud tento první gate vytvořil
kvantový stav, který je nyní teleportován na Bobův qubit, pak tento druhý by ho měl vrátit zpět, čímž Bobův qubit přivede zpět do stavu nula.
Ale to samozřejmě anuluje veškerou naši práci na teleportaci stavu. Takže bychom to nechtěli
dělat, kdybychom skutečně chtěli s teleportovaným stavem něco provést, a kdybychom ho skutečně neznal jako kvantový
stav, nemohli bychom aplikovat unitární operaci k jeho vrácení. Každopádně je to čistě pro diagnostické účely, abychom se ujistili,
že teleportace byla úspěšná. Pokud změříme Bobův qubit ve stavu nula, můžeme být přiměřeně
přesvědčeni, že teleportace fungovala. Jakmile jsme přesvědčeni, že náš protokol funguje podle očekávání, mohli bychom odstranit tuto
finální unitární operaci a skutečně s teleportovaným stavem něco udělat. Ale prozatím se jen ujistíme, že to funguje.
Spusťme circuit na kvantovém počítači. Můžeme použít Qiskit Primitive Sampler ke spuštění tohoto circuit
mnohokrát a sbírat statistiky výsledků měření. Kdybychom dokonale teleportovali Alicin stav k Bobovi pokaždé,
Bob by pokaždé změřil svůj qubit jako nula. Ale kvůli šumu prostředí a nedokonalostem v
gate můžeme očekávat, že uvidíme některé průchody, kde Bobův qubit skončí jako jedna. Ale pokud většinu
času je Bobův qubit změřen jako nula, můžeme to považovat za úspěch. Zde máme histogram výsledků měření
všech tří qubitů. Bobovo měření je zobrazeno jako první slot každého tříbitového řetězce. Jak se očekávalo, čtyři
výsledky odpovídající jeho bitu jako nula jsou mnohem pravděpodobnější než ostatní čtyři. Takže jsme úspěšně
teleportovali kvantový stav. Ale podívej se, jak daleko jsme teleportovali. Toto je mapa všech
qubitů na kvantovém procesoru, který jsme použili. A v experimentu jsme použili jen tyto tři qubity.
Alicin qubit byl tady a Bobův qubit byl tady. Takže byli skoro hned vedle sebe. Mohli bychom
dosáhnout téhož jen aplikováním pár swap gate, které – jak název napovídá – jednoduše prohodí kvantové stavy
dvou sousedních qubitů. Kvantová teleportace je užitečná pro přenos kvantových informací na velké vzdálenosti a
kvantové stavy byly teleportovány stovky kilometrů. Pro naše experimenty zde jsme omezeni
velikostí chipu, ale mohli bychom teleportaci učinit trochu působivější teleportováním stavu mezi dvěma
vzdálenými qubity na našem kvantovém počítači. Zkusme to tedy. Tady je náš nový diagram circuit. Vypadá trochu
složitěji, ale nic se fundamentálně nezměnilo – jen nyní Alice a Bob vytvoří svůj sdílený Ebit
a pak se oddělí. Tato řada čar a X reprezentuje swap gate, které přesouvají
stavy Alice a Boba z jednoho qubit na jiný. Alice se přesune na qubit 1 a
Bob se přesune dolů na qubit 12. Pak Alice vytvoří svůj náhodný stav na qubit 0 pomocí
této unitární operace. Měj na paměti, že vytváří stav poté, co se ona a Bob již
oddělili. Takže Bob je od ní již daleko.
Pak teleportační protokol pokračuje jako předtím a Bob skončí s Aliciným původním stavem po svých
podmíněných operacích. Aplikujeme inverzní unitární gate a pak ověříme, že Bobův qubit je
ve stavu nula. A znovu vidíme, že většinu času byl Bobův qubit nalezen ve stavu nula.
Teleportace tedy byla úspěšná.
Míra úspěchu ale není tak vysoká jako když byli Alice a Bob vedle sebe. Všechny ty swap gate
mohou být nákladné a způsobit, že se Ebit trochu zhorší. Kvantová teleportace se může zdát jako magie, ale jak jsme
viděli, vše, co je potřeba, je provázání, klasický komunikační kanál a trocha vynalézavosti. Původní návrh z roku 1993,
který jsme probrali v tomto videu, položil základy pro další protokoly, jako je kvantová gate
teleportace, a je nezbytnou součástí kvantových výpočtů a komunikací.
Na experimentální frontě vědci stále posouvají hranice kvantové teleportace – dokonce se jim podařilo teleportovat
kvantový stav fotonu mezi laboratoří na Zemi a satelitem 1 400 km
nad ní. A teleportovat kvantové stavy přes hlučný klasický internetový kabel. Pokud chceš teleportovat vlastní
kvantový stav, přejdi na modul kvantové teleportace odkazovaný v popisu níže. Díky za sledování
a uvidíme se příště.